regardez cette vache sous la pluie c'est
une simple bâche vous trouviez elle est
là stoïque sous la pluie elle n'est pas
malheureuse cette vache ni
particulièrement heureuse non plus elle
est juste passive dans la face au caylar
de se rapporter à cette circonstance
extérieure indépendante de sa volonté
la pluie cette vache accepte l'existence
comme elle vient elle n'en sulte pas le
ciel elle n'espère pas le retour du beau
temps
elle accepte c'est tout cette vache sous
la pluie incarne une forme de sagesse
je suis en main et vous êtes sûr
milliers de culture générale
[Musique]
cette image d'une vache sous la pluie a
été proposée par tim ferriss l'expert en
productivité de la silicon valley lors
d'une conférence ted d'avril 2010 est je
vous ai rien dans la description si vous
voulez la regarde dans cette conférence
tim ferriss utilise l'image du lavage
sous la pluie pour prêcher le stoïcisme
qui me philosophie de la grèce antique
vieille de 25 siècles aux geeks de la
silicon valley plutôt étonnant
il leur définit le stoïcisme dans leur
langue comme un système de productivité
un outil pour atteindre ses objectifs
dans l'environnement très incertain
l'entrepreneur tout particulièrement à
l'heure d'internet et de la disruption
permanent à le croire l'entrepreneur et
plus généralement l'homme hyperactif du
21e siècle devrait prendre exemple sur
la vache sous la pluie ces difficultés
le poids de ses efforts et la souffrance
ne sont pas une fatalité
le remède est ancien retour donc 25
siècles en arrière
j'ai décidé pour approfondir ma
compréhension du stoïcisme et ainsi
peut-être mieux l'appliquer au quotidien
de synthétiser entièrement ce volume de
la pléiade
intitulé les stoïciens c'est une
compilation de textes traduits par
l'historien de la philosophie
émile variées sous la direction du
philosophe pierre maxime chu cette vidéo
est donc une introduction générale au
stoïcisme parce que j'ai l'intention
dans les prochains mois de faire au fur
et à mesure d'autres vidéos sur tous les
autres textes du volet j'ai
principalement utilisé mes notes sur les
préfaces pour faire celle ci allez je
rentre dans le vif du sujet on est en
grèce antique dans la seconde moitié du
ivème siècle avant jésus-christ à
l'origine du stoïcisme il y à un homme
et non de situer à ne pas confondre avec
zénon d'elée un philosophe
présocratiques qui sévit ces deux
siècles plus tôt si tu y sommes c'est
une ville de chypre ou zénon vivait dans
une riche famille de commerçants 21 ans
il part étudier la philosophie à athènes
un peu comme les provinces au monde
aujourd'hui a pas comme ils étaient 1,2
me barbare il parlait un grec pas
terrible il s'exprimait surtout par 100
ans ce qui contrastait fortement avec
l'éloquence cultivées dans les écoles
philosophiques ce handicap de départ est
d'ailleurs peut être la source de l'art
stoïciens des conseils moreau qui
s'appelle la parrainer tic alors le
parcours de zénon et bien sûr crucial
dans l'émergence stoïcisme
mais il faut aussi reconnaître que les
circonstances est défavorable
les esprits étaient mûrs pour cette
nouvelle philosophie
tout d'abord les conflits de succession
après la mort d'alexandre le grand avait
nourri une certaine déception à l'égard
de la politique sur le plan spirituel
ensuite les grecs craignent est de moins
en moins les durs mais les i
et de platon et d'aristote leur semblait
inutilement compliquée et inversement il
trouvait les sagesse pratique trop
superficielle enfin il y avait bien la
nouvelle école des piqûres qui jouissait
d'un certain succès mais tout le monde
ne s'y reconnaissaient pas beaucoup de
grecs rechercher un autre idéal
ce sont ces hommes qui vont se grouper
autour d'eux et non epicure installe son
école à athènes dans son fameux jardin
en 306 avant jésus-christ puis ils n'ont
bien lui donner la réplique en 301 sous
un portique de l'agora la fameuse place
sociale de la cité
c'est pour ça que son école s'appelle
l'école du portique portique sesto en
engraissant siens c'est là l'origine du
mot stoïcisme
je lui ai dit les esprits étaient
particulièrement mur pour cette nouvelle
sagesse mais le succès de l'école doit
beaucoup à la personnalité de son
fondateur
ces noms men est en effet une vie qu'il
voulait exemplaire sur le plan moral
les patients étaient à ses yeux de
vraies maladies il s'habillait toujours
de la même manière ils mangeaient
simplement parler peut il était facile à
vivre
cette austérité légendaire le rendait
très populaire au point qu'il a reçu les
honneurs public à plusieurs reprises le
problème en revanche c'est que c'était
difficile pour les disciples d'imiter
une morale ou six seven
[Musique]
quand la philosophie stoïcienne était
encore toute nouvelle elle vivait
forcément une période de vie original et
les adeptes et est enthousiaste mais
cette ferveur initial de ce premier
stoïcisme des fondateurs
ap les anciens spécisme cette ferveur et
naturellement retombé au bout d'un
moment
à tel point que la doctrine de zénon est
devenu un genre de catéchisme que les
élèves apprennent par coeur et récite
devant leurs parents
l'école a même connu des défections un
peu comme dans les partis politiques
voire des trahisons comme celle du tyran
obèses denis des raclées qui fut d'abord
l'élève de ces noms avant de se
convertir l'épicurisme bref c'était un
peu la crise elle était d'autant plus
que sur le plan des idées le stoïcisme
n'était plus en phase avec les
mentalités on est de la fin du deuxième
au premier siècle avant jésus-christ à
rome où le stoïcisme a été importé avec
le reste de la civilisation grecque
philosophie stoïcienne rencontre trois
obstacles majeurs
tout d'abord les romains demande des
préceptes moraux des phrases saint clair
qu'ils énoncent des règles pour une vie
meilleure
or l'ancien stoïcisme s'était borné à
poser les principes théoriques de la
marque
ensuite les romains se remettent à leur
religion
alors que l'ancien stoïcisme n'a pas
grand chose à faire de l'eau de l'ied la
vie après la troisième obstacle
les romains sont de plus en plus épris
de science dont les explications font de
l'ombre à la vision du monde stoïcienne
avec ses trois obstacles
c'était un peu un moment darwinien pour
le stoïcisme
il lui a fallu s'adapter pour survivre
la renaissance a été principalement
l'oeuvre de deux hommes panne etios puis
son disciple posidonia les deux figures
principales de ce qu'on nomme le moyen
stoïcisme
que retenir de cette renaissance le
moyen stoïcisme et le résultat de l'
influence d'autres cours d'année tio ce
qui est parfois présenté comme la toute
première source de l'humanisme
occidental se panne et y'as a fait
évoluer la doctrine vers une morale plus
pratique en s'inspirant du cynisme par
exemple son disciple posidonia ce qui
était le prof de cicéron a pour sa part
rapproché le stoïcisme de la religion et
de la science
c'est donc grâce à ses deux réformateurs
que la philosophie de lennon a survécu
s'adaptant à l'esprit du temps nous il
faut aussi leur reconnaître de l'avoir
simplifiée de la voix allégé de pas mal
de détails dogmatique
ce qui a permis d'en faire un peu le
mode d'emploi d'une pratique moral de
plus en plus répandue ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'examen de conscience
le stoïcisme s'est ensuite propagé dans
différentes couches de la société
romaine essentiellement grâce à cissé lô
le courant a été un foyer de résistance
au despotisme des empereurs notamment
néant c'était alors une école de pensée
indépendante où on refusait de se
soumettre au culte imposé par le pouvoir
par exemple le sénateur stoïciens trajet
as dans la vie exemplaire faisait passer
néron pour un débouché s'est ouvert les
veines en 66 pour offrir son sang à
jupiter
cette résistance passive a heureusement
pris fin avec les empereurs suivant
adrien entonnant et bien sûr marc aurèle
qui étaient eux favorables au stoïcisme
là on sort des grandes époques
stoïcienne donc j'appuie sur le
champignon
le stoïcisme a une influence continue
plus ou moins implicite au cours des
siècles suivants
il a un peu imprégné les premières
théologie chrétienne
même si elle n'était pas matérialiste
son influence s'est fait plus explicite
à la renaissance où on le retrouve par
exemple dans l'introspection que mène
montaigne
dans six essais à l'époque classique des
cartes sont inspire de manière évidente
sa maxime changer ses désirs plutôt que
l'ordre du monde aurait pu sortir de la
bouche de zeno et ce ne sont que
quelques exemples parmi des plus avéré
d'après emile brayer on peut voir dans
l'inspiration space yen un facteur
constant de l'histoire de la philosophie
comme de la littérature et le stoïcisme
et même recyclé aujourd'hui par les
stars américaines du développement
personnel comme tim ferriss mail
historien de la philosophie qui est mort
en 1952 nous avait prévenus dans sa
préface les hommes auront toujours
apprendre de la sagesse de issia
aux etats unis les universitaires
spécialistes du stoïcisme ne voit pas
d'un très bon oeil
l'actuel renaissance de leur philosophie
préfère il rappelle entre autres griefs
que le stoïcisme ne se résume pas à des
compilations de slogans comme memento
mori slogan qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
spécifiquement stoïcien à l'origine
c'est vrai que le stoïcisme constitue
est au départ un système complet et
cohérent avec au centre une conception
du monde physique et autour notamment
des conceptions de la logique de la
dialectique et de la rhétorique la
fameuse morale stoïcienne n'était que le
couronnement de ce système
pour autant les spécialistes ne peuvent
pas nier qu'elle en était aussi la
partie essentielle c'est pour ça je
trouve que les discours des oracles de
l'entrepreneuriat tim ferriss sont en
réalité plutôt fidèle à l'esprit
originel du street
d'ailleurs l'école stoïcienne
fournissait des précepteurs moreau qui
devenait parfois ensuite les conseillers
politiques de leurs prestigieux élèves
et puis après tout comme l'a bien
rappelé pierre hadot dans qu'est ce que
la philosophie antique la doctrine
stoïcienne était surtout comme toute
fille lou scientiques la prescription
d'un certain mode de vie bon je referme
la parenthèse et j'en viens à son idée
un peu le nom de la chaîne
alors quelle est cette fameuse morale
stoïcienne son fondement est plutôt
simple l'individu doit conforme et ses
désirs et ses actions à l'ordre
rationnelle et divin de la nature il
faut
en d'autres termes selon epictète
vouloir que les choses
yves comme elle termine à l'instar de la
vache qui endurent passivement la pluie
le parfait stoïciens pratique le
détachement il néglige les facteurs
extérieurs qui ne dépendent pas de lui
indique ainsi de créer lui même sa
propre souffrance on peut prendre des
exemples concrets pour mieux comprendre
à quoi bon se lamenter de la météo à
quoi bon espérer le beau temps à quoi
bon s'énerver dans les bouchons est-ce
que ça va débloquer la circulation à
quoi bon pour un élève des primaires à
propos de ces mots de passe à quoi bon
pour un entrepreneur se laisser abattre
par un obstacle inattendu
la clé de la sagesse pratique stoïcienne
c'est que l'on souffre souvent
inutilement en imagination leur mettez
simplement d'accepter ce qui est et de
passer à autre chose
souviens toi écrit et peut-être que tu
es comme un acteur dans le rôle que
l'auteur qualifié
il dépend de toi de bien jouer ton rôle
mais non de le choisir
j'aime encore mieux l'image stoïcienne
du chien qui suit le mouvement de la
charrette à laquelle il est attaché à
quoi bon s'épuiser à résister autant
épouser le mouvement j'ai l'impression
que les animaux sont bien plus tôt y
tient que nous et en effet l'érudition
le raffinement de la connaissance sont
inutiles
la seule chose qui compte c'est la
certitude intérieur tiré de l'accord
intime l'ordre des choses dans la morale
matérialiste et sensualiste des
stoïciens il n'y a pas de dilemme entre
la liberté et le déterminisme
il faut simplement en durée l'existence
de la même manière que la tâche en dur à
la pluie avec un calme stoïque
[Musique]
et
le stoïcisme est une philosophie
particulièrement intéressante parce
qu'il repose sur des préceptes simples
pour améliorer l'existence la longévité
exceptionnelle de zénon tim ferriss
s'explique probablement par cette
utilité pratique mais aussi surtout par
la souplesse de la doctrine son message
principal
encore une fois c'est que l'homme est
lui même la cause principale de son
malheur de telle sorte qu'il n'est dans
son pouvoir par le détachement à l'égard
de ceux qui ne dépend pas de lui d'être
moins malheureux ou plus de religion
pour conclure je dois admettre que je
suis moi même un peu fan de cette
philosophie
son diagnostic me semble évidemment
juste elle est simple claire puisaye
coûte rien il faut juste faire l'effort
certes quotidien renouveler permanent il
faut faire l'effort de nettoyer son
esprit de toutes ces inquiétudes
inutiles
n'est ce pas qu'il est sage la vache
sous la pluie
[Musique]
si vous avez aimé la vidéo donnez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la
suivante si vous voulez lire l'article
de blogs tiré de ma lecture voir si vous
voulez vous attaquez vous même à ce
volume tous les liens sont dans la
description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser vos
commentaires enfin si vous voulez
recevoir les dernières années de culture
générale synthétisée dans le format le
plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous abonner à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse email sur le
site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale soyez stoïcien
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur
de la pensée
[Musique]